>>> FLORIDA'S GOVERNOR FACING
SOME SIGNIFICANT BACKLASH FROM
HAWKS IN HIS OWN PARTY OVER HIS
STANCE ON RUSSIA'S WAR IN
UKRAINE.
THE FLORIDA GOVERNOR AND LIKELY
PRESIDENTIAL CANDIDATE DREW A
LINE IN THE SAND WHEN HE TOLD
FOX NEWS HE DOESN'T THINK
PROTECTING UKRAINE IS VITAL TO
U.S. INTERESTS.
INSTEAD, HE CALLED IT A
TERRITORIAL DISPUTE AND A
DISTRACTION FROM BIGGER
CHALLENGES AT HOME.
THIS MORNING TOP SENATE
REPUBLICANS ARE PUSHING BACK.
LISTEN.
>> OUR TERRITORIAL DISPUTE IN
THE SENSE THAT ANY MORE THAN IT
WILL BE A TERRITORIAL DISPUTE IF
THE UNITED STATES DECIDED THEY
WANTED TO TAKE CANADA OR THE
BAHAMAS.
>> TO SAY THIS DOESN'T MATTER IS
TO SAY THAT WAR CRIMES DON'T
MATTER.
HE'S GOING TO GO BEYOND UKRAINE,
PUTIN, IF YOU DON'T GET THAT AND
LISTEN TO WHAT HE'S SAYING THIS
IS A CHANCE TO STOP PUTIN BEFORE
IT GETS TO BE A BIGGER WAR.
AND CHINA'S WATCHING.
>> THAT'S RUBIO GRAHAM THERE.
THERE ARE OTHERS.
SO JOINING US NOW, CORRESPONDENT
FOR "THE NEW YORK TIMES."
GOOD MORNING TO YOU.
WHAT DO YOU MAKE OF THIS DIVIDE
IN THE REPUBLICAN PARTY ON
UKRAINE AS WE WERE TALKING THIS
MORNING IN THE MEETING, KAITLAN
SAID THIS IS NOT JUST MEMBERS --
THESE ARE HAWKS WHO ARE
DISAGREEING ARE RON DeSANTIS.
>> THIS IS A BIG MOMENT FOR THE
REPUBLICAN PARTY AND ITS OWN
EVOLUTION ON FOREIGN POLICY AND
IT'S A BIG MOMENT FOR THE 2024
CAMPAIGN.
>> HOW SO?
>> THE REPUBLICAN PARTY
HISTORICALLY IS HAWKISH.
THEY'VE BEEN WANTING TO PROJECT
STRENGTH AGAINST RUSSIA AND
ABROAD.
DONALD TRUMP SAID WE WANT TO
STRIKE HERE AT HOME.
THE WHOLE AMERICA FIRST AGENDA.
THAT WAS AN OUTLIAR.
THEY MAKE UP THE VAST MAJORITY
OF SUPPORT IN THE POTENTIAL 2024
FIELD.
NOW THEY'RE BOTH COMING IN ON
THAT SIDE OF THE LEDGER.
SO THAT'S A BIG SHIFT FOR THE
PARTY ITSELF.
IT'S REALLY NOTABLE.
YOU SEE MARCO RUBIO AND LINDSEY
GRAHAM.
HE IS SUPPORTING DONALD TRUMP
BUT CHOOSING TO CRITICIZE RON
DeSANTIS FOR AGREEING THE
CANDIDATE HE IS BACKING IN 2024.
>> RUBIO SAYING HE DOESN'T DEAL
WITH FOREIGN POLICY EVERY DAY AS
GOVERNOR.
HE'S THE SENIOR SENATOR IN HIS
STATE.
WHEN IT COMES TO LINDSEY GRAHAM
SAYING, YOU KNOW, TO SAY YOU
DON'T CARE ABOUT WAR CRIMES,
WHAT RAN DeSANTIS IS MORE
NUANCE.
HE WAS NOT SAYING THAT.
IT IS INTERESTING.
RON DeSANTIS PREVIOUSLY
SUPPORTED ARMING UKRAINE AS
POPPY POINTED OUT YESTERDAY.
I THINK WHAT IS MOST FASCINATING
ABOUT THIS IS GETTING THE FIRST
LOOK AT RON DeSANTIS' FOREIGN
POLICY.
>> ABSOLUTELY.
HE'S BEEN A BLANK SLATE ON THIS
ISSUE.
RUBIO IS NOT WRONG.
IN TALLAHASSEE, FOREIGN ISSUES
ARE NOT CENTRAL.
RON DeSANTIS IS CHOOSING THIS
AND THIS THE FIRST BIG THING HE
IS SAYING.
HE CHOSE TO GIVE HIS OPINION TO
TUCKER CARLSON WHO HAS BEEN
ALIGNED WITH TRUMP ON SHIFTING
THE REPUBLICAN PARTY IN THIS
DIRECTION.
ITS NO THE JUST THE ANNOUNCEMENT
ITSELF OF THE POSITION, WHERE HE
ANNOUNCED IT AND HOW HE
ANNOUNCED IT AND WHEN HE
ANNOUNCED IT.
HE IS RUNNING FOR PRESIDENT AT
THIS POINT.
>> BUT TO TRY TO ENACT YOUR
FOREIGN POLICY POSITION YOU HAVE
TO BECOME PRESIDENT.
TO BECOME PRESIDENT, YOU HAVE TO
GET GOP VOTERS BEHIND YOU.
COULD THIS NOT BE A VERY SAVVY
MOVE BY HIM LOOKING AT HOW MUCH
REPUBLICAN SUPPORT FOR THE ON
GOING LEVEL OF FUNDING AT LEAST
FOR THE WAR IN UKRAINE HAS
DWINDLED SIGNIFICANTLY?
>> HE'S ABSOLUTELY ALIGNING
HIMSELF WHERE HE THINKS THE
MAJORITY OF THE REPUBLICAN PARTY
ELECTORATE IS.
THAT SAID, IF YOU BECOME
PRESIDENT AND YOU DON'T WANT
TO -- IF YOU WANT TO GO BACK TO
HIS PREVIOUS POSITION, IT'S VERY
HARD TO SHIFT.
IF YOU SAID THAT UKRAINE IS NOT
PART OF THE VITAL NATIONAL
SECURITY INTEREST FOR THE UNITED
STATES, IT'S GOING TO BE HARD TO
MAKE THE CASE IF YOU BECOME A
PRESIDENT DeSANTIS TO THE
CONGRESS THAT YOU SHOULD BE
PUTTING MONEY INTO SOMETHING
THAT'S NOT VITAL.
>> YEAH.
>> HE LEFT THE DOOR OPEN A
LITTLE BIT.
>> A LITTLE BIT.
>> YEAH.
>> ON THE OTHER HAND, DO YOU
POINT OUT THAT TRUMP IS THE ONE
WHO IS FOLLOWING DeSANTIS AND
I'M TALKING ABOUT HOW HE'S
TALKING ABOUT EDUCATION?
?
>> YEAH.
YOU KNOW, I WATCHED TRUMP'S
RALLY THIS WEEKEND.
IT WAS AN EDUCATION SPEECH IN
IOWA.
IT WAS REALLY A TRUMP SPEECH
WITH A LITTLE EDUCATION IN THE
MIDDLE TOWARD THE END.
BUT IT WAS INTERESTING JUST TO
SEE HOW HE IS ADOPTING SOME OF
THE SAME LANGUAGE AND SOME OF
THE SAME SORT OF EMPHASIS.
EDUCATION IS A DEFINING THING --
>> SCHOOLS AND --
>> ON SCHOOLS AND CRITICAL RACE
THEORY.
THERE IS A MOMENT WHERE HE IS
TALKING AND TALKS ABOUT CRITICAL
RACE THEORY AND TRANCE -- TRANS
GENDER.
HE TAKES IT IN.
HE SAYS, WOW, THAT WAS A LOUD
MOMENT.
YOU CAN SEE HIM SAYING THIS IS
MOTIVATING THE BASE WHICH IS
SOMETHING THAT DeSANTIS SAW
FIRST.
>> IT IS FASCINATING HOW THEY
TRY TO DISTINGUISH THEMSELVES ON
THINGS LIKE THAT